yeah welcome to 5-minute game here watch
the player let's go let's go inform and
try the more I gambit again I accepted
this quickly and of course I'm I done
don't really know what I'm doing it must
admit that ya know I'm probably I'm ok
thread and e5 I wanted to say not quite
sure what Queenie fibers makes the real
crush to me to be honest what if I just
detective five sir why can I not take it
on d6 some trick ok I guess he's just
playing a couple of quick moves without
any particular idea when this can hardly
be good for black what put surprise me
so on what should you do now maybe
Bishop to d2 and I might a Quincy five
some sort of double attack yeah I played
this in 15 seconds 15 seconds
unbelievable or maybe this is really a
theoretical line and I'm just stupid not
so possible ok I could also retreat the
bishop but then you would take this made
only one yum this is the annoying thing
play Bishop
for like a one I need to play a movie em
yeah probably will take on c4 otherwise
I don't want cap then no this this act
don't understand at all I mean now to
bishops in an open position why would
why would you take on f3 really hard to
understand so be five so now I can play
all kinds of things if I've may be
attacking the rook attacking the night
so I can just take the rook right what's
what's the big point okay let's take the
rook so what now take here yeah it takes
on c4 this is maybe not one hundred
percent clear you might have two should
be seven if I play some some bishop
moves in my player should be seven okay
let's check here I would have the good
porn on d6 yeah frightening t7 know who
this is this helpful here Bishop c5 to
e7 stuff like that I thought so
yeah okay now can take on c4 with check
simply I'm sorry shouldn't be too bad ya
know I have just this t6 pawn & Young
should be it should be rather strong and
he allows me to play the 17 surprising
December nobody has roop the ATM okay so
let's just make sure that this pawn is
is covered with Bishop c5 from safely
they also could have taken probably so
now I'm threatening just t 7t 7 Bishop
e7 and over okay I can just play this
then there's nothing here there should
be seven and I'm promoting yeah all this
there are no counter threats at all
Queen f7 now against RK you can click
windy six maybe this is some the last
kind of last kind of trick in the
position so Queen e6 yeah maybe Queen
six sounds better time morning
threatening Queenie aid and keeping an
eye on this check sir
yeah ok so now take just here and Bishop
f3 mmm you have got this and win the
bishop yeah this is just a row black
resigns yeah I think this is this
opening is weird when I didn't really
refute it yeah this is just just just a
very bad move why not take see for
bishops are the business Bishop is
clearly stronger than the night ok aunty
85 yeah rook rook back to you one that's
probably better out but this is also
quite quite comfortable k f6 i don't
know i mean it's it's a pawn and add the
position basically yeah okay this miss
Morrow has struck again and we are
meeting just played on moves the tempo
without any kind of computer d I guess
yeah thanks for watching